there's been a ton of hype for the
iphone 14 lineup coming later this year
especially thanks to some major changes
and differences like the new dual cutout
face id sensors instead of the notch and
some absolutely huge changes in the
camera features however we just got some
absolutely terrible news about the
lineup yes we just got a report from
nikkei asia saying that at least one
iphone 14 model is three weeks behind
schedule due to the china lockdowns so
what i'm gonna do in this video is
explain exactly why and how we got to
this point why apple is so far behind
with the iphone 14 lineup how they could
potentially
fix it and deliver the iphone 14 lineup
on time in september and i'm also going
to share the latest brand new leaks and
rumors that we just got so without
further ado let's jump into this new
report according to the supply chain
sources who spoke to nikkei asia they
said it's challenging to make up for the
lost time now of course they're talking
about all the lockdowns that have been
happening in shanghai and in general in
china since sometime in march they said
apple and its suppliers are working
around the clock to speed up development
adding that the pace of reopening in
shanghai is rather slow and because of
that it seems like apple has fallen
three weeks behind in terms of the
iphone 14 lineup schedule and that's
very important because apple has a very
tight lock on the schedule they do
things like right before
the iphone actually gets a release is
when they start the mass production so
if they're behind by three weeks this
means we could realistically get late
iphones this year but the interesting
detail to look at is that it could be at
least one iphone 14 model that gets
delayed which means that maybe some of
them come on time and then some of them
come a little bit later and
interestingly the reason for that is
because there are certain suppliers like
china's luxury precision industry that
have orders to build two out of the four
models this year so there are different
companies that work on different models
and the reason this is such a serious
deal right now is that although shanghai
has recently loosened their lockdowns
there are still some neighborhood
enforcers that are keeping large parts
of shanghai
in lockdown despite the actual official
easing of the lockdowns that are
happening right now so who knows what's
going gonna be happening and adding to
that on may 6 we actually got some
security footage released of an apple
plant in i believe it was uh the quanta
plant in shanghai
of the workers actually riding and
jumping over the security checkpoints
over there so i'm not going to show the
video but it was pretty crazy to see and
earlier this month ming chi kuo who has
been a reliable apple analyst for many
years he's basically famous in the apple
tech space he reported earlier this
month may 4th that june through august
is going to be critical for ramping up
new iphone production because if the
lockdowns aren't removed before june
then the iphone production capacity
likely including iphone 14 may still be
affected by logistics and workforce
allocation and making things even worse
he said that china's policies could have
a more significant impact on consumer
electronics on the demand side than the
production side saying that there could
actually be a recession with demand
going down because people are focusing
on their necessities like food water
medicine instead of actually spending
money on consumer electronics so that
could be an even bigger issue out of all
of these supply chain disruptions and
adding on to that just a couple of days
ago he said that many companies and
investors expect improved production
after shanghai actually reopens however
he said his latest survey indicates that
there is already some evidence that
lowering consumer confidence and
worsening inflation is weakening and
destroying consumer electronics demand
and that actually includes apple
products with the demand disappearing
not deferring and this is actually a
really big deal because it impacts
china's gdp numbers directly and that is
exactly what matters in terms of seeing
if they're in a recession or not because
if they are going into a recession
that's going to impact everything in
china from the supply side to the
production side everything and check out
this report from jpmorgan yesterday they
said we downgraded our china gdp
forecast again now looking for second
quarter gdp to contract negative 5.4
percent compared to their previous
estimate of negative 1.5 that is a
absolutely terrible estimate showing
that they are likely going to be going
into recession and they even said that
their quarter two global growth forecast
stands at just 0.6
growth that's the global economy which
means that we could be getting close to
a global recession saying that it's
easily the weakest quarter since the
great financial crisis outside of 2020.
and now if you think this is just
isolated to china it could actually be
an issue here in the united states as
well because in the first quarter of
2022 our us gdp dropped by 1.4
that means we actually had a quarter
that was negative so if this current
second quarter is negative that means we
will technically be in a recession for
the first half of this year and maybe
even longer and check this out just this
morning atlanta fed's gdp now estimate
for real gdp growth in q2 is 1.8
down from 2.4 on may 18th that's just
one week ago so we are now just 1.8
percent from a recession and the reason
this is such a big deal is because
previously before we got that really bad
negative 1.4 percent readout for quarter
one the estimate was brought down from
1.3 percent on april 19th all the way
down to 0.4
on april 26th within two weeks
everything changed from an estimate of
plus 1.3 all the way to negative 1.4
which is a massive deal so this 1.8
estimate for the second quarter could
change very quickly and now getting back
to china things got even worse for the
iphone 14 lineup earlier this month
because on may 4th foxconn abruptly
halted hiring at the iphone factory amid
a new lockdown and iphone 14 delay
concern so that's even worse for the
iphone because they just stopped hiring
because of the new lockdown so it's just
such a bad thing over there but luckily
just a couple of days ago apple actually
asked foxconn to start iphone recruiting
or hiring
two months early like this is completely
unique they are probably so worried
about the iphone 14s getting delayed
that they're actually hiring two months
in advance to make sure they can build
up a stock and not have to delay the
iphone and if you didn't already know
apple actually did delay the iphone two
years ago in
2020 because on july 30th apple
confirmed that the new iphones would not
arrive in september and that was a huge
shock to a lot of people and of course
those delays were once again from
lockdowns that happened and basically
slowed everything down and the crazier
thing is they not only delayed the
iphone 12 lineup but they delayed half
of them for another month so it wasn't
until november 13th when you could
actually buy the iphone 12 mini and the
12 pro max and that definitely impacted
sales and that really sucked for me
because i bought the 12 pro max and i
had to wait a couple of months extra
compared to the usual september release
date until i could actually get my hands
on that iphone so going back to the
original article there's a chance that
if some delays happen we could actually
get like a half release with two of the
models getting released on time and two
of them getting delayed just like it
happened in 2020 and in my opinion the
one model that i think is going to get
delayed is the new iphone 14 max model
which basically has basic features but
the larger 6.7 inch size with the notch
because that's going to be a new design
that apple hasn't really done before
with the aluminum chassis and the
regular features so there might be more
delays in terms of that model so i think
what kind of makes sense is apple could
have the regular iphone 14 model and
then the iphone 14 pro max so the people
who want the iphone 14 max they could be
tempted to actually upgrade to the 14
pro max model instead of waiting for
that regular max model that could come a
month later alongside the regular 6.1
inch iphone 14 pro model but once again
hopefully apple's move of hiring workers
two months early completely stops all
these delays and we actually get all of
them in september now i do want to go
through some new leaks and changes in
rumors because i think these new iphones
are going to be absolutely incredible
now first of all from page tech just
came out with a new video showing off
some new exclusive renders by ian's
elbow showing off this new purple color
which i think is very very subtle but it
does look pretty nice honestly and as
you can see we have the new dual hole
punch cutout which i think looks awesome
we have the new thinner bezels and in
this render you can actually see the
sensors that are behind it we have the
camera we have i believe the dot
projector combo right here and
potentially the infrared camera right
there and then he also showed off these
other angles with the actual camera and
man looking at these renders i am so
excited for the iphone 14 pro models i
mean this just looks so incredibly clean
and if you think the new purple pro
color sounds crazy well it looks like
all of the rumors and leaks are adding
up and it's most likely that we are
getting a new purple color option
because we got some leaks from chinese
social media site weibo basically
showing that purple is the most likely
new option but moving on to some new
leaked features that we should expect
mischief did say last month that the
iphone 14 models will likely feature
upgraded front cameras with autofocus
and very recently we saw that all iphone
14 models are gonna gain two
front-facing camera upgrades of course
that's the autofocus and the wider f 1.9
aperture which is basically gonna
increase the light input that comes into
the sensor and give you sharper better
photos with less noise and i think
that's going to be a huge deal and then
on top of that we actually got
confirmation from ross young that he
believes that the new iphone displays
for the pro models are going to match
the new ones that are on the samsung's
which means that they can refresh down
to one hertz refresh rate instead of the
current 10 hertz on the 13 pro model so
that's gonna go from one hertz to 120
hertz with promotion and because of that
there is a chance that apple could
finally be giving us an always-on
display mode which i've been asking for
for years now so hopefully we get that
and the last thing i want to show you
guys before i finish up this video is my
personal thoughts on hopefully this new
bronze slash copper finish because i
think this would be a much better choice
from apple to give us this bronze color
compared to the new purple which
honestly doesn't look that much
different compared to the current blue
that we have which honestly i don't
really like so
if we get this bronze color i think that
would sell a lot of the pro models so
there you guys go hopefully you enjoy
this video and if you completely
disagree and you don't think that the
iphones are getting delayed let me know
down below but if you enjoyed the video
click the circle about to subscribe and
definitely check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]